Hello everyone.
Welcome to talk to Google on Kevin Bell
today.
We are very pleased to welcome Mr John Boyega from Star Wars episode seven,
Force Awakens.
[inaudible]
oh good.
Oh,
fantastic.
I never do that,
I suppose.
No.
So welcome.
Um,
huge movie.
so we'll start off kind of with you in your beginning and your life.
You grew up in southeast London.
Yes.
And so you got involved with acting and stage work and uh,
then right into tap dancing,
dance.
Drew.
So what drew a Jj and Kathleen Kennedy and Lawrence,
uh,
for you for this role?
What,
what,
what was it?
Um,
I mean it all started four years ago.
I was going to say a long time ago in a galaxy,
but far away,
but I'm not going to do that.
Wait,
we're in a room full of nerds,
aren't we?
Oh,
I'm home.
great.
I've met Jj at bad robot.
I went to me,
he's producing partner.
And then,
um,
as I was walking to go in and meet his producing partner,
I saw Tom Cruise and JJ Abrams just walk out of a room.
I was kind of like,
okay,
that's Tom Cruise.
Cool.
And then,
uh,
Jj walked up to me and just expressed how much he loved my first ever film a tap
the block.
And uh,
he said you guys watched it.
Oh yeah.
Great.
And then he said that I love you in the movie.
One day I'll get you in something,
we'll just have to think of,
of what's of what's right.
And then four years later the opportunity came through for me.
By the way,
my agent is,
is,
is at the back.
You should probably give him a round of applause.
[inaudible]
I was released into a world of auditioning for the biggest role of my life.
Well,
I mean,
so you said it,
so you kind of were getting out.
Jj Abrams is a huge kind of geeking out about star wars and stuff like that.
So what was it like working on set with him and just being on these iconic set
someone up from the original trilogy and also some of the original characters?
Yeah,
I mean I had no shame on a star wars set.
I still have no shame.
This is the only time I'm going to experience star wars like this for the first
time.
Um,
and so for me,
I just,
I geeked out as much as I could.
I brought merchandise to set for various cost members to sign.
I did,
I took selfies like Harrison,
he wouldn't take it.
Take your selfie.
We're working together kid.
And it was,
it was nice to know just having that experience.
Uh,
but it's,
it's always nice.
I run around the Millennium Park and I had a fat burger right by the chest set
on the Millennium Falcon.
Like I,
you know,
I lived on that thing.
I had a good time.
And so your character Finn is a,
we seem as a storm trooper.
It's one of the first shots that we actually see in the teaser trailer when this
first came out.
Um,
and eventually you team up with these like Grizzly carrot characters,
ray Han solo BB eight.
So what can you tell us about,
that's not sport?
Like,
I know we can't do that,
but what can you tell us about your character in terms of just who fit is
personality wise?
Is he angry?
Is He sad?
Yeah.
Courageous.
What,
what,
what is his character?
Um,
it's been sweating.
Finn Finn is a very interesting character as you know,
like the,
the clones,
uh,
before,
did not match up positive day five years that we've missed.
And so now storm troopers actually bred from birth their babies and Brett to
fight,
uh,
from,
from a young,
a young age.
And Finn,
it was just one of the many storm troopers,
but something ignited in,
in,
in the young lad.
And he escapes the first order.
And then he ends up on Jack Hu and he finds the piece of full ray pay by Daisy
Ridley and,
uh,
the Bull Bba,
I call him the ball.
But yeah,
they'd BBA and they all go off on a,
an amazing adventure together in which they encounter you.
And the old,
that was my highest.
And again,
by the way.
So what inspirations in terms of,
uh,
actors or characters from previous movies where you kind of drawing from to
develop them?
Um,
it was so funny.
Uh,
my second to last audition,
which was a screen test,
I was contemplating what it,
what it is to be fin and what it means to be,
be a character who is so unique and uh,
and charismatic and,
and somewhat awkward in this big universe who doesn't fit in.
Um,
and I,
I re I went on Youtube,
I should have said Google button.
Ama Cause Youtube.
All right,
where are we on them?
Oh,
you do?
Yeah.
So I went on Youtube
and,
um,
there's a amazing video of Harrison Ford and Mark Hamill's original audition
tape.
You should see it off of this,
off of this talk.
And I watched it and I don't know what it is.
It's just star wars energy.
In a normal movie.
If your ship was on fire and you're about to die,
you know,
there'll be phone calls to the family,
tell them I love them.
Oh,
Kestrel music,
boom,
the end install wars is like,
hit the lightspeed.
Woo.
I'm not,
for me it was like,
you know,
a great way of experience in [inaudible].
So I kind of embodied that in my audition.
That's great.
Uh,
and so we're just,
what's incredible about this movie and about just watching the trailers and just
get,
everyone's getting excited.
It's kind of the return of practical effects and practical sets and in real
locations.
So what were some of the most impressive sets or puppeteers or or puppets,
I mean,
um,
or characters that you got to work with them?
Sure.
For me it was the first time I went on set was in Abu Dhabi and Jack who was
real,
like JJ is so dope.
He had the droids move in,
in between takes that makes it feel like Disneyland.
Like they actually,
they're like,
they exist.
I felt like a kid,
like those creatures would move and you know,
and I'm just there like,
well,
I wear a real planet.
This is the closest we're ever going to get to Iti.
Um,
and so it was amazing to see the practical effects puppetry and a metronics,
um,
or played a vital part.
And the CG is just an enhancement of what's already there.
So it's good to know that Jj went back to 1977
there.
Was there a person on this stuff that you,
besides daisy,
who you really get along with the best and you really connected with?
Harrison's my best friend.
Um,
he wouldn't say exactly like that,
but that's what he means.
Well,
I mean we,
we,
we've had it,
we've had a really good bond.
I think one of the things I'm most excited for people to discover,
it's fin and Han Solo's relationship.
It's fin has no respect for him.
And in return the Han Solo is just,
you know,
like this snotty little kid that it's a great combination and the,
and,
and a great chemistry.
So Harrison is someone that I got to spend a lot of time with
in Lawrence,
Kansas and came back to write the film.
Yes.
He wrote empire strikes back and return of the Jedi.
So what was it like kind of having,
was he,
was he there on set?
Was He helping you with your character in star wars kind of folklore and stuff?
Yeah,
absolutely.
I mean,
he collaborated with JJ a lot and he was on set to,
to tweak the,
the scripts.
And you know,
what's great about Larry and in terms of weight in terms of the way he writes,
is that there is space for you to put your input into,
into the dialogue.
I think that specifically with me and daisy,
we had to create these characters from scratch.
And to have a right to the,
uh,
enables you to breathe in between the dialogue is great.
So you can throw in some Improv,
um,
and it,
and it works out well.
Is it daunting to,
cause you're kind of taking on,
you're creating a brand new character in this universe.
So is that a little daunting for you as well?
I mean,
June the auditions,
it was because it,
you,
you had I had,
before I present to you in a few days,
I had to present it to Disney.
I had to present fin to JJ and I had to be,
it had to be approved to before come into you guys who are the ultimate judges.
You guys are the gods that decide whether a film does well or not.
Uh,
and you know,
that was the time when I was kind of like this,
this could either be really bad or I can work hard and it could be good.
Well that's actually interesting too.
Cause now that you have,
you know,
episode seven is done.
So now with Ryan Johnson picking on him,
so they do you have influence over your character now?
Like to say I like,
I feel like you should be doing this
episode eight.
Can we talk about,
you caught me in my little sneaky.
That's fine.
Survives finserve um,
so we have some questions from uh,
some,
uh,
Googlers who Dana Hung Klein's gonna.
Fabulous.
Read on.
So our first question from the global audience is,
what is your favorite piece of star wars paraphernalia that you own?
Ooh,
I have a lot.
Um,
I have,
uh,
a a star wars comic book that's actually based on the first draft that George
Lucas ever,
ever wrote.
And Luke Skywalker is called Luke stock.
Kayla Han Solo is like an alien,
like a furry thing.
And it's all different.
It was his first ever draft that they made into a comic book.
Um,
and,
and I own that and I love it dearly.
Femi can we check the,
I still have that.
I'm going to read it again.
Um,
so who would you,
John,
not your character.
Uh,
rather facing a fight the aliens of Star Wars or the aliens of attack.
The block.
The aliens have a tap the block every day,
all day because it's fun
and they're more dumb.
So then survival is,
is pretty much guaranteed.
I'm sorry for the rest of the costs,
but yeah,
definitely getting into the top of the block.
Uh,
what was your hardest day on set that you can tell us about it?
Hottest Day on set.
That's such a good one.
Gosh,
Jj.
Um,
I was obviously,
as you've seen from the,
from the,
the trailers,
me and daisy are in a really intense scene where there are Thai fights is
chasing us down and not loads of explosions.
And,
um,
the scene starts here with Jj just saying,
okay,
just run from here to there.
Make sure you fit your dialogue in within that space.
Make it fast,
make it actually,
this is star wars,
have fun.
I'm like,
okay,
cool.
Jj backs all the way up.
Jj goes further.
Jj goes behind a plastic tent,
the camera's covered up.
Crofty starts to go away.
And I'm like,
what's going on?
And on.
Daisy was just like,
I think there's going to be explosions.
I was that three,
two,
one.
I think it was hard.
It was like,
okay.
Again,
we've done that so many times,
but it looks fun.
It looks fantastic.
Well,
that's so your heart's dance that what was the most exciting day besides the
first day you were on set where you just stopped and just,
I think made the most exciting day is,
uh,
receiving the light saber.
Um,
obviously we know Finn Battles.
a storm trooper that has an amazing Tom Fhfa,
and the day they handed me that say bond called action.
It was,
uh,
it was a glorious day.
The cost is in ruins.
There was storm troopers everywhere.
I had a light saber.
I was just like,
I'm legit.
The black antiquing right?
Yeah.
No.
Uh,
amongst you and your costars not their characters.
Who Do you think could make the Kessel run in less than 12?
Parsecs
oh
my gosh.
Carrie Fisher.
I mean it'd be a hard land.
We probably hit lightspeed before we hit a rock,
but Carrie Fisher would definitely get us there for sure.
And finally we hear you're pretty good impressions.
We already heard one today.
Do you have a favorite star wars universe impression aside from Han?
Apparently
uh,
dual or do not.
There is no try.
We have some audience questions.
Well,
so the mikes are opening up for audience so thanks so much for being here John.
No problem.
Quick question.
Hopefully you can answer without doing any spoilers.
Why is fin out of breath and every shot?
I don't know.
This is messed up.
You messed up.
Thanks.
I was like Jj,
my,
you've got to clean me up in this man.
Do some Michael Bay stuff.
Do you know what's so funny about that?
I love that.
I think we're too used to seeing characters that have it figured out with to
where you used to heroes who are in trailers just like this.
She much have him out of breath looking awkward and let's see if he ever rises
to glory.
That's why I say so.
I commend Jj for having me sweating wall up in that tree.
Okay.
Can you tell us your experience the first time watching star wars?
Um,
I watched star wars last week,
none.
And I did my first,
my first,
the time watching star wars was when the phantom menace came out.
Um,
I'm a nineties baby.
It was born in 19 to soak it up.
Old People.
Oh yeah.
Young people in the house.
Um,
I'm then I watched the phantom menace.
By the time I wasn't really interested in character arcs and story.
I didn't know much about it.
I just saw lasers and ships and stuff like,
okay,
cool,
I'll watch it.
And then after I watched the prequels,
I then found out about the originals and started reading the comics time play
the video games,
and then I was just a star wars.
And that for the rest of my life.
Yeah.
Great.
Was there a character that you wanted to play,
like you identified most with and the films?
I know,
you know what I'm going to say it's on so low because everything,
I don't know.
I love the character that represents us.
To be honest.
If each individual here was in star wars,
you would not be Luke Skywalker come on.
You weren't being like trying to fight the forces of good and all that kind of
stuff.
You'd be on trying to make money as a bible.
Yeah,
that's why I like,
that's why I like him so much.
Um,
so just kind of like playing off your Instagram reaction to the trailer,
which is one of the funniest things I've ever seen.
Have you seen the movie and if so,
did you react like that during the film?
You know,
it's so funny.
I was so steel during the film.
Kathy Kennedy was next to me watching it together.
Um,
and it's,
it's,
it's just so strange.
Like I was there obviously when all these films were shot,
but it's strange thing and everything edited together.
And seeing visual effects here in the music.
John William kills it in this movie.
And you know,
I was just like,
oh my gosh,
I'm watching stole his we've,
and I'm in the store,
me by my name.
Yeah.
I'm in it.
Oh my gosh,
that's me.
Yeah.
That's how I react to it.
After the air,
you don't throw you the,
were like a bunch of Nobel stone in the universe,
like a throne.
Mara [inaudible] father,
like kind of iconic characters,
but now they are not there.
So have you read all those books or what's your opinion about the,
a lot of the extended universe books and,
um,
I mean,
I'm not,
I'm not really into the stall with comics as much as I'm into like the marvels
and the dcs.
It's just because I experienced,
I was through the movies.
Um,
but I do love playing the video game.
Is anyone playing battlefront at the guys?
You would never beat me.
Literally.
I am so good.
Um,
so yeah,
that's,
that's my experience of the books and stuff.
Um,
I,
so I had another question about your reaction video.
Uh,
obviously we're really excited.
was that your first chance to let people know,
like your friends and family that you are,
I mean basically a jet I in this movie like,
and how hard was it to keep that in?
I don't know what the Jeddah is.
What was that?
No idea.
It's just some guy in a leather jacket,
right?
Yeah,
I dunno.
Um,
I was,
I mean that was the first time I ever saw the trailer and the,
the main frame it was just put together in the way that shocked me.
So I had to jump over the,
so far for a second.
But it wasn't the first time I had shared my excitement.
My Mom and dad got to come on set,
you know,
while I,
while I was filming.
And actually they,
they came on set when I was doing the lightsaber battle with,
with the storm trooper.
My Mum was crying.
She was just like,
don't let that white thing hard to how my dad was just like,
go on,
knock him out,
knock him out.
Did your parents like Star Wars?
Where the,
did they?
My mom doesn't have no idea what it is.
No idea.
I'm like mom,
Luke Skywalker clay.
Once it'd be a jet,
the force is,
she's like,
when do you show up?
All right,
I'm going to be that guy and not ask about star wars.
Um,
and just since you already brought it up,
what do you think happened to Moses and his crew out there of the events of
attack the block?
Do they keep fighting aliens or does he get out of prison?
What?
I doubled off of the film,
one of the top of the block.
I pitched an idea to Joe and I said we could have a teaser trailer with just the
Big Ben.
There are more aliens that come down and Moses is just galloping across
Westminster Bridge on a police horse with a nice,
with loads more use around him just to go to war.
So I think Moses is back on the streets and uh,
he,
he's definitely up for killing way aliens for sure.
Awesome.
Thank you.
So going back to the,
uh,
the expanded universe a bit,
obviously Disney d canonized a lot of it.
Is there,
is there some bit of it that you wish,
uh,
was,
was persisted into the,
uh,
the episode seven?
It would,
it would have been good to discover,
um,
Darth Vader's secret apprentice.
Uh,
it would have been good to discover that to see how he kind of would mesh with
the,
with the franchise films.
But I think the main thing I trust what we would give him before in terms of the
films I always think is important to expand on the original story.
Um,
and even though we don't get to experience the expanded universe,
there are risks being taken in force awakens that won't make it the same old
story.
So we,
we will still feel like we're getting a piece of the expanded stories.
That's great.
Thanks.
I'm curious to get your honest opinion on the ridge or the prequel trilogy.
I,
nobody else is gonna see this,
so he can just say what you really think.
Okay.
Um,
when I watched the prequels,
all I saw with imagery and I was young cause I wasn't really looking for what
you guys hold most dear,
which is you guys love the character arcs.
You guys love the,
the,
the fight between good and evil a space opera.
I wasn't looking for that win when I watched the prequels.
All I was looking for with action explosions.
So it was great for me.
Um,
and I,
I was touched by revenge of the fifth.
I enjoyed it at the end.
In the end,
the ending was,
was quite touching to me to see how it joins up to the other other stories.
A lot of people are very critical about them and I get it,
but the force awakens is not that Disney were we supposed to do
one more question.
Okay.
I kind of in the same vein as this question,
uh,
how personally responsible do you feel for whether this movie's a success or a
failure?
You don't want to be the next charge our banks,
right?
That would be awful.
Um,
I,
I don't feel responsible,
but to what,
I've already got my escape plan through the tunnel on 45th street,
you guys will never see me again.
Um,
uh,
you know,
we,
we all feel responsible that we all do.
Um,
um,
I remember Ted in Harrison,
like,
dude,
if this flops,
I'm standing behind you make,
you're going to take most of it,
but it's not going through.
It's going to be amazing.
I just know it because there's this,
there's a general feeling in a natural,
uh,
geekiness that connects all star wars fans and it,
and it touched me in,
if it can't touch me,
I know that he's going to touch everybody else,
but the guy that we really need to pray for is JJ Abrams because I mean,
the most pressure is,
is,
is on him.
You know,
we,
we as actors,
we come in,
we filmed the project to just go by j j see you later.
Oh yeah.
Good luck editing the film.
And so I think he turned into Moses and one of the biblical characters growing
facial hair in the editing room because he was there for a long time.
But he's done a fantastic job.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Well,
thank you so much.
Star Wars
episode seven the force awakens comes out December 18th with some showings on
the 17th so it's lovely to meet you.